oh i feel sorry for david hazel he's
been so patient sat there and
yeah you're now live whatever he's
taking i'll have some of that
um right
so we're sorry councillor hutchins
you're going to um
put forward your proposal chair i got my
hand up
oh big apartment oh yeah you so you have
counselor leather
go ahead go ahead thank you chair well
the report now we're back into
part one the bottom age six there's an
awful lot of money mentioned
now if i heard right in our part two
are we not we're only talking about the
hundred and ten thousand
from the nlrf grant money
yes so what about the rest of
of what's shown at the bottom page six i
mean
we're looking at paying well they will
have had by the end of uh
this month about
three what 300 313 000 there had
233 000 pounds probably by the end of
this month
as well as the our management fee of 128
nearly
11 000 pounds a month i mean they've
been having an awful lot of money 16 10
for doing nothing
and i don't see how if we just pay them
that 110
that the government have granted they
can't open the pools with that that's
for sure
so and there's there's also the ongoing
what twenty one thousand pounds a month
up to the end of september mentioned at
the top of page seven after they had
sixty thousand pound restart grant
saying
there's an awful lot in this report that
you know the public have a right to to
know what we're doing about it
okay i said it i said before i'm not
play i'm not going to vote for another
hate me
to be paid to 1610 under the present
circumstances
and then we'll be in default then won't
we yeah
our contract we'll be in default of our
contract puts them in the shining light
i'd rather that
you know it won't there's perfectly good
reasons why they've had so much money
out of us
and done nothing over 12 months because
of the shutdown but they've had an awful
lot of money from us and yet they want
even more
yeah well i'd be point taken but um life
is what it is at the moment i'm afraid
um
councilor hutches did you uh
where are you yeah thank you chair um
councillor leather i completely agree
with what you're saying i think they've
been paid far too much money however
we do have some money from the leisure
facilities grant which i believe that
money could be used
to at least get us through the next few
months to reopening which then buys us
some time for the reports we've been
talking about
which we can then discuss further as a
council any further support
but what this does my proposal will give
the officers the chance to actually
reopen the facilities
along with the government roadmap which
is more important at the moment is
getting those facilities open
yeah i think there's a general agreement
on that so you've got your proposal
there councillor hutchins
uh so my proposal is the council will
work with 1610 to reopen
all three facilities in line with the
government roadmap
the 110 000 pounds from the leisure
facilities grants
may be used to assist with reopening at
the discretion of
officers right
um steve hurst will that cover it chairs
just i was just gonna ask
one one question um based on the
proposal that come
from 1610 in so far as
um torridge poole and torrent and pool
they've indicated being able to open
those facilities
um between the 12th of april
and the 17th of may but
worthy pool's been indicated it's not
possible to
open in line with the government's
roadmap
and that it won't be possible to open
that until
uh the end of may
right so that's something for i i'm not
quite sure
how counselor hatching's his
uh proposal would fit in with
the proposal that 1610 have already made
to us
i are you suggesting that if they don't
uh comply with being open on the 12th of
april
at holesworthy because they've indicated
that's not possible
councillor hutchins do you you allowing
officers just
discretion to be able to negotiate with
1610 to be able to
resolve the problem with holdsworthy
because it is a little bit different to
the others
i think that as a i think they would
have to report back to
our next full council um and tell us
exactly what the plan is
uh right but it but if they don't open
presumably they would be in breach of
contract
right okay so you would your proposal
then would still
cover that eventuality you think yeah
yeah
all right okay sorry
i'll second that thank you well i think
we had to
originally councillor hutchins was
seconded by councillor jones
okay yes
this councillor hatching satisfied that
his proposal ties in with what we've
just
approved under part two he said that
this council will work with
1610 that that presupposes that there
will be a satisfactory
um result from the health safety issues
yes yes they councillor haines they
ain't going nowhere
unless they comply with health and
safety
regularly just checking no matter where
the
finances are irrelevant if they
comply they must comply
so i don't see there's a problem there
but well i'm gonna vote anyhow
um because i'm beginning to lose the
will to live here
and uh you know the nearer i creep to my
wicker coughing uh
you know that's the way it's going at
the moment so
um we've got the proposition on the
table it's been seconded
and uh now we will vote on it
thank you chair councillor belton for
pastor brenton four
councillor craigie boar councillor darts
paul thank you councillor gov
for councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or
councillor harding or councillor hawkins
paul councillor happle or
hicks or
councillor hudson or councillor hurley
for council hutchings or
councillor inch
thank you councillor james or
councillor jones or
councillor landford or councillor laws
or councillor leather against
councillor locke councillor manly
four councillor mcgoff
four council mackenzie
ball councillor newton
oh councillor pennington
we need to be a strong council so i'll
go for four
thank you councillor watson
councillor wiseman oh
right
i give us 31 four and two against chair
thank you very much councillors good
so um ah i'd like to point out that uh
had these facilities been in-house under
our control we wouldn't have had this
meeting tonight but there you go
that's such his life um i would like to
say that uh
those of you on the planning committee
will be getting an email from me
tomorrow but uh
so stanford baited breath on that one um
in the meantime i think we've uh
exhausted ourselves to see
yeah sorry there's a couple of extra
items on the agenda
i beg your pardons absolutely you must
get a new chairman this is rubbish
okay so we've got petitions then item
eight
now none of them notice emotion there's
none of them
so have i covered it yes sir
thank you so much tom approval from you
means so much to me
i couldn't do without it so thank you
very much officers
thank you very much members i think most
people spoke tonight only a couple
didn't
there you go so uh